[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the famed
or rather infamous cuddly theory that is
the theory that dudley dussley
ended up marrying ravencore graduate cho
chang
let me just say first off that this
isn't my theory
i've seen this theory on the internet
before however what i want to do today
is first present it to you guys and then
give you my take on the theory
discussing whether or not it's plausible
so let's look at the elements of the
theory
this theory came about for a couple of
reasons but the main driver behind it is
that cho chang ended up marrying
a mughal that's canon cho chang married
a mughal
furthermore we also know that dudley
dursley ends up getting married himself
but the name of his wife is never
revealed this is basically the
entire basis for the theory an unnamed
wife and an unnamed muggle
we know dudley desley is a muggle and
while it's unusual for witches
wizards to marry muggles it definitely
still happens
however the main issue with witches
wizards marrying muggles
is that it will often cause problems
later on we saw this with snaim's
parents
which eileen prince and muggle tobias
snape as well as with mcgonagall's
parents
which isabelle ross and muggle robert
mcgonigle
it happens but usually not without
conflict this is because when a which or
wizard is pursuing a muggle
they need to take the international
statute of secrecy
into consideration that is the rules put
in place to ensure
that the wizarding world is kept a
secret often when a witch or wizard is
courting a potential muggle spouse
they fail to mention their magical
abilities which causes tension on the
line when their kids start performing
magic
themselves the guilt eventually becomes
unbearable
and they end up confessing their magical
status to their other half
however the years of lies are not often
entirely understood
so in this respect the relationship
between cho and dudley
does sort of make sense if cho were to
have married a regular mughal
then she would have no doubt encountered
the aforementioned difficulties
associated with
muggle courtship however if she were to
end up with dudley who was a muggle
there is the obvious advantage that she
would never have to hide anything from
him
dudley was privy to the magical world
and there wouldn't have been much that
cho could have said to him
to put him off or surprise him okay now
i know what you're thinking
cho and dudley dudley was about as awful
as a young boy could be
he tormented harry he was ruthless to
the other children and he was about as
spoiled and pompous as you can get
however there was a point in dudley's
life at which he hit a bit of a
crossroads
the dementor attack though the dementors
weren't able to successfully suck out
dudley's soul
the attack still had a profound impact
on him as it forced him to observe the
type of person that he was
this is reinforced by jk rowling in an
interview
people usually ask me what is it that
dudley saw during the dementor attack
rowling said my feeling is that he saw
himself
exactly for what he was and for a boy
that spoiled it would be terrifying
so he was jolted out of it dementor
attacks aren't usually good for people
but this one was this basically confirms
the deadly changed
we know for a fact the dudley later felt
remorse of the way that he treated harry
as a boy
dudley and harry even later go on to
have a bit of an awkward albeit
respectable relationship as adults
joe chang was born sometime between 1978
and 1979
and attended hogwarts from 1990 to 1997
where she was sorted into ravenclaw
house she was a bright witch
and even had a brief flame with harry
potter himself however their
relationship eventually fell apart
due to her best friend betraying
dumbledore's army before harry cho was
in love with cedric diggory
and after his demise she certainly had a
tough time in school
she really was a lovely young woman and
i can completely see why she ended up
marrying a mughal
just wanting to escape all of the
madness of the wizarding world
so who better than the new and improved
dudley dursley
who better to marry than a witch when
you're trying to leave your life of
prejudice behind
and who better to marry than a magically
informed muggle when you're trying to
ditch a fully-fledged magical existence
i think the theory is highly unlikely
but possible
it's certainly something to think about
and chadley really rolls off the tongue
what do you guys think was chadley the
thing let me know in the comment section
below until next time i am what i am and
i'm not ashamed
[Music]
you